Oh
Upstairs
F-HOW'S GOING BROS?
What's good? Can this video hit 10 million likes, dammit, no
Welcome back to another episode of resident evil three. You bros really love this, huh? Don't yah? *Awkward laugh*
It's been a while since we had a series with this much ehh enthusiasm, for me playing.
Uhh
Bad news for me is I am the biggest fucking pussy  of all time apparently.
Thank you very much..great..
It's scary
Also can we talk about the field of view in this fucking game...who HOLDS a knife like fucking this!
Alright? (Chuckle)
I'm fuking ready for ya boy!
domo arigato :3
Hello-- Ayy, I'm out! I'm free. I'm free everybody.
Just gonna close this door, there we go...
How's everyone doing? Oh my god this place is huage
It's huage bros.
Oh god...
Okay, we're- we're out but, we're not safe yet!
Don't worry...there's a herb here (;
That's right
I saw it
Gunpowder
I need all my shit. That I can get
to survive this shit
Luckily it's a, ya know, less scary now
I was really, really not happy, too happy about last episode.
Let's see what happens in here!
Hello?
Shaddup
OH this is our new...
area.
Cool
Nice and cozy, I like it :D
Is there anything we can put here?
I don't fuckin' know.
Wait I can sleep?
*gasp*
oOH
A broken gun
What am I gonna do with that shit?
SAVE STATION!
Gotta love my save station. :DD
What else we got
EYY!!
HELLOO
Oh my gawd
Can I wear this? (WTF pewds)
pls
Must be Zoe's
heh
alright.
*chuckles*
ho hO alright.
Zoella?
Are you there?
I found your bra
I know this is a lil weird for me to
...
God dammit.
Must've changed her number
Aye
We got uh
...
Whatever the fuck that is
Uh, steroids.
Please,
okay great.
I need a key, I suppose.
Stabilizers
Alright
Please chicken nuggets
GAWD
DAMMIT
Hey it's that beautiful picture again
Another coin...
More of these fuckin
another gun.
Aaand
a TV.
*phone ringing*
FO FUCK'S SAKE ZOE
God dammit.
Alright here we go
Yes
I did
What does that mean
I thought I was out
So is mine
Great
Dude your mother, is fine.
I wouldn't worry bout your mother
I already dealt with the daddy..
Alright, not a problem, not a pro-
this looks very Fallout-y.
Quite cosy, I like wha- I love what you've done with the place.
What the fuck are all these things?
What the hell did I just pick up...
supplements.
Can't be used as it is
must...
okay
HEY LOOK IT'S A HEAD
Hey how you doin' buddy
just layin'
okay I'll let you chill there
I gotta go near the water
I mean we're clearly infected as well
Cause like we lost our arm and it was totally fine,
and the way we kept getting hurt or whatever
PLOT TWIST
we can't go in this one?
I suppose we gotta go here bros
Alright nice,
nice cosy little...
I feel a lot better today,
can you-can you tell
I feel great
I feel fantastic,
near the water.
Hey how's everyone-
fuck
Aw shit.
This is where she ran.
Fuck man, are those babies? (yep)
Aw I love babies.
LOVE what you done with the place!
Yeah this is where Mia ran
Fuck, they make a creepy noise
nnNNLOX! (?)
BBWEOX! (OH, box)
'Sright box I don't play around.
You're cool.
Ya cool
You're fine.
BLEBHH
BAWX! *shit*
no? okay.
Hey, how's everyone doin' in here?
aw
AWEUUUGH
Fuckin'
UGH, FUCK OFF
fawk off
fawk owf
dats fokin rite
jeezus christ
It's bigger than my asshole..(of course pewds)
my god..
It looks like a plan for some sort of flamethrower
It looks like a plan for some sorta flam thrower
hey hey hay
don't think I don't fuckin' see you
Don't think i don't fucking see you
Don't think I don't fucking see you (other subtitle girl here waddup)
slash and dash and blash (??)
slice!
slice and dice (dies? idk)  and blice
and dice!
and blice!?
Get the fuck away, get the fuck away
get the fuck away get the fuck away
get the fuck away
okay
That's cool
I like flamethrowers
I like flamthrowers
I like to burn shit
Not a problem
O ma fucking god what the fuck is that
What the fuck is that
Don't like this
Oh god
oh god, oh god
Gotta get out (x3)
Don't slice the beehives
Don't slice the beehives, got it
Got it
AH fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck ,fuck, fuck
Goddamn these things are so fucking annoying!
It's like a little "top o' the mornin' t' ya!" in my face
Let's go here
Ah for fuck's sake
How do i deal with these
How do I deal with these?
She's upstairs don't go up
*reads the game subtitles*
Fucking don't tell me what to do
Fuck off!
I'm not gonna die f.. okay fuck off
Honestly, you're being super annoying
Super, super
Super.. Super
HOW THE FUCK DO I DEAL WITH THESE MOTHERFUCKERS??
Kay, we got a mouse-
mousemap (he means house map)
Hey I made it, how about that (Congratz)
Is the spider ornament missing?
Fuck it is
Okay, we gotta find the spider ornament
Got anything good?
BAWKS
Right, this is not going too good
Not gonna lie
You might wanna get checked on those fucking mosquitos
Hey garbage!
HEYYY
Fuck
Do I need chem fluid?
Do I need chem fluids?
I need health alright shut the fuck.. shut the fuck (burps)UP
I'm trying here
Heyy
Okay
"Burner Grip"
Burner grip
It can be combined with something else
We need that fucking flamethrower
I WANT that fucking flamethrower
I Want that fucking flamethrower
I Deserve.. I think I Deserve a flamethrower
I dunno about you
I don't know about you but I think
But I think I deserve it
I've done pretty well in my l.. Hey this place looks nice
I've done pretty well in my life
Hey! This place looks nice! :o
You can now c.. Thank fucking god
Thank fucking god!
SAVE STATION  :D
♪SAVE STATION♪
Gotta love my-
♪GOTTA LOVE MY S..♪
Okay well that was fast
Am I doing good? (ye u are Pewds)
(Hight voice) You doing great Pewds (normal voice) Aw thank you!
Finally, someones being nice to me! c:
Oh my god
Good thing I just fucking.. dropped a bunch of shit that I needed
Alright, we got our new hang-out place
What else do we need for the flamethrower? We saw the plans before.
I'm not too happy about.. this
Not gonna lie
The fuck did I just do
AHEY HEY look at that! Hey
*laughs*
Yeah no I did it *laughs*
YeAH no yeah hey I did it
I can place anything there? really? :D
hEY OMMY GOD  I SOLVED THE PUZZLE
Hey oh my god I solved da puzzle
OH MY GOD
Alright well I- I suppose we got-
HEy its that picture of me again
dammn I look good! (totally)
damn that's instagramable!
Fuck yeah
Oh my god
Ah those fucking mosquitos
A KNIFE! a knife! a slice!
im from of hood motherfuckers!
that's right sweden! we're all hard! >:D
HELL YEAH
Not even a problem
NOt even a problem
If y'all gonna bring mosquitos up my ass
Better bring da bigger ones (uh ya sure?)
Cause I got a KNIEFE
I got a fucking kneef
Not a knife a kneef
Ready to.. aAHH
Who did that
okay
It's fine, it's fine
's fine
Shawty! (Shotgun shells)
Got-
Gosh
OHMYGOD
Look how many there are
Are those spiders?
AUGH I hate spooders
Nice spooders
Nice nice spi- AGH
Nice nice.. aH fuck fu.. je.. fu.. fu.. je.. shut da fuck up shut da fuck up
FUCK SHU-FU- Shut the FUCk uP
Why does everything attack me-
Why does everything attack me
AAAH ON MY HAND EW EW
AHH THEY'RE ON MY HANDS UUGH UUGH
What'd I get?
Okay I can burn shit I clearly need to start burning shit
Excusez moi
Mademoiselle (french speaking ya know)
OH My god you're fucking huge
I just need
uhhh
just need a flamethrower
I don't think that's too much to ask
I asked Santa
So apparently the boxes, you have to rotate them
and then you can open them
Yes *gasps* a lockpick
See I didn't know that. How am I supposed to know that?
(Leafy-ish voice) Uh pewdipie fukin idiot how can u not know that
I'm like fucking.. I don't fucking know
aAH it's huge
Go away
Disgusting
Where did it go? Fuck
Oh god it's even huger (thats what she said :P)
I'm just gonna go in fuck you guys
A'right get a job
Get a fucking job
Heyyy
What's happening everyone
Can I combine?
Ahh I would like to..
with..
Heyy
Oh I did it (congratz)
Hii Hoa we did it
Now it's time to fucking burn some motherfucking mosquitos
Although I really wanna make another..
Maybe if I heal..
I need to heal anyway
'nd then I get the herb
A'right well it's time to play with my fucking rules
Aye mosquitos
More like..
I don't wanna.. I don't wanna waste it actually
Fuck
There we go
Not a problem
Who's that
Loch ness?
More like suck-a-dickness (wowOw 10/10 comedy)
Got 'em
Aye mosquitos
More like..
Umm
Go-fucking-diesquitos
Got 'em
(Whiny voice) oOh no your little home died, well that's too fucking bad
Next time don't be a f..
oOh my god it didn't work it didn't work it didn't work it didn't work it didn't work
Why won't you fucking die jesus christ
Rude
How do I kill it I need to kill it
How is it not dead yet?
Fuck, I've wasted so much
(are you) Kidding me
Ah fuck, I need a lever or some shit
This is.. I'm not.. I'm not too good at games alright
I'm fucking trying, that's all you need to know a'right fine, I'll find it
..find it. Hello?
Fuck
They don't like me, I don't know what I did
bUUURRRN
THAT'S RAAAAHHGT >:D
FUCK YOU MOTHAFUCKKA
NOpe Shut the fuck up
K.. What've we got?
Chem fluid and chem fluid
Can I.. I need all of those
Where's my uh fucking hub station I.. I'm lost
Shut the fuck up
Fine 'm fine
Doing great
In fact I'm doing quite swell
I am proud of myself okay? I don't need you tuh.. be condescending to me in the comments all the time
Just me 'nd ma knaif
And my bros
We stab people.. not a big deal
Damn I look good
Evrytiem
*kissing teeth* Damn
*slurp* So sexy
Fuck yeah
Now.. where were we? idk
Aaaah oh yeah
The cabinet
The spooder cabinet
Mine aand fucking mine thank you very much spiders fucking assholes
How are you guys with insects and shit I'm like..(like wut)
Flame rounds.. ammo for granade launcher
Well I don't fucking have a granade launcher do I?
Okay
Happy about that
O my gawd
Can you kindly fuck off (anything for senpai)
It won't fucking die will it?
It's like fucking layers it's like onions
Hey look at that I cleared a path for everyone
My name is Jacksepticoeye
Okay
A'right I'm happy about that
Let me just-uh squeeze right through here buddy
Hey buddy you London? (ayy phandom waddup) lol
Sorry
Oop
Heyy almost missed you
Top o' the mornin' t' ya
*Doing a funny impression of Jse idek what he's saying*
Great
aAyy I'll take that
*girl voice* Hello?
How ya doin buddy?
Heyy how ya doin?
Hey baby
Good to see you
Gimme a kiss
Yeah no more bullshit
Aah yada yada yada yada
That's me
*Laughs*
That's funny
*Keeps laughing*
Ayy lmao look at that I found the thing fucking hell
Sorry but I don't really give a shit about you Mia anymore
You're kind of a..
Kind of like not worth it a'right?
There are other asses out there
a'right that I can be tappin' right now
Yours is pretty.. pretty low on the list.. Mia
Thank you very much
More like Mia don't wanna, ha, see ya haha (dammit the puns)
aAH
I-
eehhhhhhhhhhh! (tf)
No, no, (deck the halls tune) no no no no no no no
no no no no no, no no no no
AaAH
What the fuck is happening?
Fuck off
Ah shit they're fucking everywhere now
Excuse me, uh, mosquitoes
would you kindly fucking die?
Aye, aye aye aye
Who said that?
Are there more-
Fuck off, like honestly. I'm fucking done. I'm done. I'm done. (same)
I'm dun. |-/
Stop
Stop. Everyone, stop.
Onion
That's right fucking onions.
Is it dead? I don't care. I don't care.
At this point, I'm done.
I'm done.
Great.
Glad we did this.
It's fine. I know where I need to go.
I don't fucking need any of this bullshit, alright?
I had a long day.
Fuck.
Okay, I'm just gonna go.
I'm just gonna go.
Hey buddy.
Hey buddy, hey buddy
London (ayyee)
Lat's talk about it.
I can't. I - I -
Fuck off. Fuck off.
Honestly.
Shh-fucking pain in my ass.
Damn. I look good tho
Damn, I look good.
Damn. I look good tho. (We get it pewds)
This is going excellent.
I'm very proud of myself.
Alright. Let's do this spooder test.
See if po-
Ah! Oh!
I think I got it there.
I think I-
I think I had it there for a...
That's a spooder.
That's a spooder right there.
Hell yeah!
I know my spooders.
I know-
This whole fucking place?
Surr*burp*ounded by spooders.
There's spooders everywhere.
Don't like it.
Not-
Not a fan of spooders (same).
Where was I?
Oh yeah.
I should do a quick save, shouldn't I?
What do you think?
Tell me. *click wink*
Love you, too.
You're so nice to me.
Love this little place I've got going here.
"I shouldn't have wasted so much flamethrower fuel?"
Well...
You know uh... hahahahahaha *deep breath*
Yeah. You're probably right. *laughs*
They came everywhere!
What am I supposed to do?
Just be like *fart noise*
No?
Exactly. (what)
And look at this.
I know what I'm-
No.
I know what I'm doing. Alright?
I'm good with this.
Seems pretty good.
Pretty good, Bros.
Look at that.
Look how much ammo I have.
Aren't you proud of me?
I'm proud of me.
Here we go.
Let's go through the-
*creepy female groans*
Oh!
What?
Bitch is coming?
Well, fuck that. I'm out.
Oh god. Is there spiders?
Why aren't you walking dude? Don't be a fucking pussy.
-Eww-
*disgusted sounds*
Ugh!
It's fine. (No it's not)
They can't hurt you. (That's true.)
Unless there's like a million of them.
(Thanks for the nightmares.)
They can probably eat you.
(Ugh)
Fucking bugs, man. (No thanks)
Never liked that movie. Bugs, the movie.
I never- never- we never was a fan of it.
Eh. Too many bugs. *war flashbacks*
Too many bugs. (*shivers*)
Hey!
Hey!!
Oh!
Oooh!!
So, we went there.
As Mia, and we got caught.
So, we need the sparrow key, I think.
Or some shit like that.
"Zoe,
You tried to sneak up on the second floor again, didn't you?"
She types very nice.
I like her handwriting.
Alright.
Aye!
Ayyyyee!
Come on. I need solid fuel.
Everyone has that ra-
Lying around in their house, don't they?
Come on, you know it.
I know it.
Ummm...
This fucking place sucks, alright?
Fucking hate bugs.
I can suck a big fat bug dick. (plz don't)
Oh.
Ohohohohohoho.
-Santa makes a cameo-
BAWKS (box)
That's right, Box.
Ain't nobody fuck with my-
Oh god whada-
Ayy lmao what the fuck!
"Ey. Pewdiepie!"
"You're not doing to great, are you, Pewdiepie?"
Hey, I'm trying.
I got a crank.
Oh I ne- I know where we use that.
It's pretty straightforward, isn't it?
Well, no wonder she got fucking caught down here.(idiot)
It's a dead fucking end.
-Uelggh- Disgusting.
Ah! No.
Don't make me kill you.
Hey x4
Hey buddy.
He-he-he-hey!
WHOAHP!
GOT EM!
Fuck you.
Not even a problem.
Not even a fukin preblem.
-Ei-ni-nai-ri-nai-rin-
(must be some ancient prayer)
Oh you wanna-
You brought a knife-
You gotta-
-pprapp-
Got em.
Got em. Hey! We can crank this!
I can crank yo' ass.
bOi.
There's clearly something down there.
I thought for sure I could use it-
Oh! There we go. Okay.
Crank it up. ♪
♪ Whenever you feel like shit. ♫
♫ Just-
Oh! There we go. Very nice.
Alright.
Can I take the crank back?
I can.
Excellent.
Saves us a little bit of time, doesn't it?
Alright. Nobody-
Nobody fuck with me right now.
Imma-
I've a bad hair day.
Wait.
Wrong way.
Now.
Okay.
Alright x4
I'm goin'.
Eyy,
You're a cocksucker.
Shut the fuck up.
Oh!
That's-
That's where I need to go.
How do I get there?
Damn, she look thick as fuck though.
Honestly.
Like, I would tap it.
Don't tell Marzia though. (got ya pewds)
Wa-was that awkward?
Have we gotten a little silent there?
Sorry. My bad.
My bad.
She's not a scary as Jack.
I don't know what it is.
Like.
I- usually, women scares me more but
She's just a fucking granny. You know?
She's got bugs and shit.
I don't give a fuck.
Do I look like I give a fuck, Mr. Kitty?
"Hell no. You don't look like you give any shits."
That's fucking right, Mr. Kitty.
She's such a fucking cunt.
Like, honestly.
"Fucking SHITCOCK" *HAHAHAHA*
*Laughs some more*
Shitcock  *shakes head* That's-
Gets me every time.
Alright-
I don't know. I-
She's in the fucking way.
Like, I don't wanna-
it's just so fucking annoying.
She's still here.
I swear to god.
This is video game logics.
If- heh-
If I don't see them, they don't see me.
Right?
Hopada-whoppada
That fucking worked?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god x2
Fuck off.
Fuck off, mosquitoes.
Jesus.
Satans.
Fucking shi-
I don't have time for mosquitoes.
Fuck off.
Oh! I got them.
There's one more.
Fuck.
Knife!
Got em.
Nice.
That was fucking nice.
He-Hell to the yeah.
We did it.
Oh so you see your health on the watch.
I didn't realize that. (srsly pewds it's been so obvious the whole time)
I never w- looked at my watch.
I don't know which button I even use to look at it with.
Fuck. I'm a pro.
Well. (lol)
Good time. Cause I fucking need it
Alright. The crow should be in here.
There it is. Nice.
And in the toilet of course, we'd find some treasures.
(sounds legit)
Fuck I don't have enough space for the coin (wtf game logic)
Let's check the window and see if she's in there.
Yeah. She is.
S- Wait for her to leave.
Here it is.
Here's the bridge.
Okay.
Alright.
We're good.
Sorta.
Not really.
Not fucking at all. (door in 3)
(2)
(1)
*SCREAMS*
NoOOOO!
FUCKING ASSHOLE!
HEY!
BITCH!
Have you heard of- ah- fuck-
I was gonna flame her.
Nooooooooo!
I hate water. Not water.
Not water.
Fuck you, Granny.
What do I do now?
Granny, why don't you come and fuck off.
What do I do?!
Fuck off!!
Oh! Oh!!
♪ Get up. Get up. Get out♪ - Ow.
We've been fuckin!
I've put IT in her asshole.
That's right mother fucker.
I'm going up.
I don't like it.
I don't like holes.
Except Zoe's hole ;D
Got em! Got em!
Fuck. This one tho.
Fuck.
Okay. This is not going great.
It's not going great.
(Look at that concentration)
(Go kill em, Pewds)
*intense lip biting*
Go. Go.
Ah.
How do I get rid of her?
I don't know. I honestly don't know.
(Oh no. Pewds is mad.)
(U ded)
Are you fucking kidding me?
Did I make it? For real?
What?! (wot)
I mean-
YEAH B- SON! *laughs*
I legit had given up.
I didn't think I would make it.
Great.
Alright.
Nice!
!
Huh!
Well. I wasted all my fucking ammo.
I didn't think shotgun ammo worked on that bitch.
Not gonna lie.
Hey look. It's me.
Wow.
So pretty.
Oh god.
"Target acquired?"
Oh hey. It's jacksepticeye.
Nice.
"Regarding the series serum"
"The following items be able synthesize serum."
"D-Series cranial nerve"
"D-Series peripheral nerve"
I think that's it as well, my man.
Mah buddy.
Mah boo.
Mah bae.
Mah bow.
My bro.
Mah ho.
Ah-
Zoe, please.
Please.
I'm looting right no-
Okay, fine.
Hallo?
What up?
It's your boy.
Yes, I did.
And her fucking bugs. That's fucking right.
heh "Sorry about that."
Of course. As we all do. As we-
No I want to get out of here.
Hey.
Hey. Zoe. Alright.
Alright.
Fuck. I didn't mean to click that. That's fucking annoying.
I wonder if there's like some weird easter eggs in the game. Like that-
If you lift the phone at certain times, you hear something or some shit.
So this is a serum but I-
Create the serum.
I suppose I gotta create it here, huh?
So we're just gonna have to go back.
Not too shabby.
Pretty proud of myself. I didn't die there.
It goes to say that-
-Y-you know-
-Never give up.
Hey. It's jacksepticeye.
Cute.
Excellent.
YES!!
Fuck yeah.
Wasted all my shit on that bitch.
Oh fuck's sake. More mosquitoes.
I'm fuken ready.
Ye better bring it, bitch.
"Ah ma gad."
"It's pewdepa-"
Shut the fuck up.
Whoa!
I didn't know you can kill them.
What???
This changes everything.
What is that??
It's a scale.
So I need another lantern.
Perhaps, grandma's lantern?
Could that be it?
Let's go back and check on good ol' granny, y'know
Maybe she's having a-
Swell ol' time, you know?
Yo, Granny~
eeYo hoo~
Granny Gru. I love you. Granny, granny, granny G-
Ah. Fuck. That bitch is still alive isn't she?
I'm just gonna go for your-
Ah.
Fuck.
That's creepy.
Can I at least save here?
It saved, didn't it?
Ey yoh. Granny.
Oh Granny.
Dim- Damn.
You know what?I have second thoughts about going down there.
To be honest. I have a lot of second thoughts.
About-
I don't know if SPECIAL is the right word there, Ethan.
Bradberreh
I think the right word is uh...
Fucking grotesque.
Absolutely disgusting.
I would rather die than going down this moist hole.
But as long as there are not anymore moist monsters.
I think we'll be fine.
S- I guess that was like a pre-boss battle.
I dunno.
What do you think?
Hey! We're out!
Okay.
That's cool. At least, we can save now.
I believe.
Tre- another treasure photo.
Wait. Are we on the other side of it? Aren't we?
Maybe we can open the gate.
I really want to save.
It really bothers me when-
Yeah okay cool.
Alright. So, Granny is still alive. We need to find her lantern.
Let's go in our little trailer park and have a lil' schnack?
Maybe some pringles. I don't know.
♪ ♫ Save station! ♪ ♫
♪ ♫ Gotta fucking love my save station ♪ ♫ (10/10 splendid pewds singing voice)
I reckon we're gonna be here a while.
Oh wow. Sounded great.
Is this where we were?
Oh!
Nice.
The fuck is up there?
Should we go up there? (Nope!)
(well you're going anyway)
Hell yeah we're gonna go up there.
Another treasure photo.
So... next to a toilet.
Okay.
I'll keep in mind next time I take a shiet.
Just no more fucking bugs. (plz)
Ah. Jeez.
I'll be right there, granneh!
Or mommeh?
Or papi
Da fuck did I just grab?
Why am I finding everything that I don't need.
There it is.
Okay.
Fuck.
What do I drop now?
Okay, we're back.
Um...
Let's make some...
I think ammo seems more precious than health in this game.
And just as I said that. *laughs* (lol) Great.
Lockpick?
What do we got?
Flame rounds.
Don't need 'em. At all. Fuck's sake.
Hey Granny. How you doing down there, boi?
Oh god.
Love what you've done with the place, Granny.
'Kay. Can't go in there.
I'm okay with that.
Fuck it's so dark.
We need our lantern.
What is this?
The gate is -
N-Well, no fucking shit Sherlock!
Okay.
-sees box-
*deep breath*
BOOOXXXXaaaahhh *exhales*
Dat felt good.
Yo hoo~♪
Granny, you in there?
You in there girl?
Oh I can't? I'm too fat :(
Can I burn this maybe?
No. Not worth it.
So where do I go then?
I would like to use them...
Now I wish we'd be able to find items easier.
Oh for fuck's sake
Ah. Jeez.
Go away spooders.
Ain't no body like you, spooders.
Thank you very much tho
Thank you for serving this country.
Oh god.
aye
Fuck. I always get the part that I don't fucking need.
I think we got a big fight coming up. (Ya think)
Wait. W- We're here now?
Oh.
Upstairs.
*SCREAMS*
UH
Please die. (plz)
Oh. My. Fucking. God.
You look great, granny.
Uh...
How you doing there?
Great.
Thanks for the hug, granny.
I always appreciate your support in everything I do.
It's always good to have a nanny.
What?
Oh Jesus Fucking Christ.
What happened to you?!
We used to be cool.
I thought we were cool, granny. Like honestly.
Ya kinda pissing me off now. ;-;
Go away spooders.
GRANNEH
GRANNEH! >:(
uh
You've got something in your fanny, granny.
Alright, that's cool
It's fine.
Don't care.
Not uhh...
Not too much of a fan of granny right now.
I think she's uh.. She's kind of a bitch
Uhh..
Okay.
Granny, can you fuck off honestly m8
Oops
Uhh..
Fuck.
Uh it's okay.
Ehuhh granny
Granny don't come here
It's a dead end, granny. You don't want to come here.
♫ Run run run rUN RUN RUN RUN run run run run run. ♫
Shit.
Whoa what?!
Go back to where you came from, granny.
Really?
Are you fucking kidding me.
Okay.
Let me just sniff the bra. [sniffs intensely]
So apparently, you use the coins on the cages.
For upgrades.
F- so this one takes 3 coins
5 coins
Uhh 9 coins.
9 coins for a gun?
A magnum
That's pretty good.
So that's what the cages are for.
Now, we have quite a few coins.
So I think we should do something about that
Reloading speed
Ugh
Aaand let's use it.
And it heals us aswell that's good.
Here we go. Say hi to granny
[comedic time-lapse music]
*and we see ethan scream again...you're gonna wanna hear this all over again, do you?*
Are you fucking kidding me.
It takes so fucking long.
It's so annoying 'cause the fight takes so long and it's just- you fuck up a little bit and you're fucking dead.
That's essentially this fight.
Don't like it.
Oh she doesn't hit you! (When you block)
Just fucking give it up, granny.
Getting tired of you right now.
She dead?
She dead. She dead. She dead.
FUCK YEA!
WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
HELL YEAH, GRANNY!
You're looking like ermm..
Uhhh... Mmm errr. (stoned?)
YEAH!
GOT 'EM! (thx)
"Jast fukin stay dead, okai?"
FUCKING STAY DEAD! That's right motherfucker we got the lantern, high five!
That wasn't too bad. Actually I have like a lot of stuff left.
So that might have worked out better than expected!
Let's go back
To the f--
Uh lantern thing.
Hey look at that that's some more ammo. (health.)
*fancy finger snap transition*
Oh hey look! This disappears now.
Wow amazin'.
Thank you granny. I hope it's a shortcut.
Eyyy more of that. Thanks granny.
Hey granny maybe wasn't so bad after all.
Ohh okay just a shortcut
♪ Save station gotta love my save station.
Cool! Thanks! We did another episode
The ama- The amazing support of these videos really means a lot I read all of the comments I appreciate all the feedback
(what about the subtitle guys ;-; (ikr))
And- and uhh. That you bros are so into it I think it's really cool I'm really loving playing this game and I'll see you all tomorrow with another episode!
As always, stay awesome, Bros.
(ok bye pewdiepie <3)